foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong my name is Mark Ellis I'm not
important it's it's so super to have
Jacqueline Coley joining me once again
as the co-host for this episode
Jacqueline because it is super Sunday in
a mere matter of days and I know that
we're not here to talk football but you
and I are big fans so my question to you
is do you do Super Bowl parties do you
go big do you stay home by yourself and
watch it what's the Jaclyn Coley
play here
Ava let me host a party or let me be at
home I don't want to go to other
people's parties necessarily and I
haven't hosted a party in a long time
but I'm much more like
basically I don't want to be where I
have to wear jeans to watch the Super
Bowl
so wait so if you're hosting a party you
don't have to wear pants is that what
you're saying no
really you've been to my house no laughs
house pants but they're house pants I'm
just such an old man when it comes to
this now because I don't like going to
Super Bowl parties I want to hear the
game I want to hear the broadcast I want
to be able to focus on it and so it's
just me and Molly the Wonder Dog most
years but the last time and maybe the
only time since I've been in Los Angeles
that I had people to my place to watch
the Super Bowl uh one of those
participants was the young man who's
going to be our special guest today
before we introduce him and a very funny
story about that Super Bowl we got to
talk about the movie that we have as our
subject today it is Suicide Squad ah it
is the the suit not a Suicide Squad The
Suicide Squad directed by James Gunn and
that is of course 90
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
an 82 percent audience score so you had
Suicide Squad come out with 2016 and
we've already covered that on an episode
of RT is wrong with our good friend Roxy
stryer and now we're talking about the
suicide squad with another good friend
of ours the one the only he started out
as a mirror intern in which point in
time he was known as Josh the intern and
then he was upgraded to Engineers who he
was known as Josh the engineer he is
Josh Tapia by birth but we know him as j
t e j t e you're back how in the hell
are you I'm doing really good you know
I'm still you know speaking of Super
Bowls and yes the
it was the game where Malcolm Butler
made the amazing interception at the
one-yard line I then exploded out of my
seat and I for some reason I had to do
something I think I believe I started
jumping on your bed I like ran to your
bedroom started jumping on your bed
Molly started attacking me because she
didn't know what was going on and I you
know I don't apologize for it what am I
supposed to do it's one of the greatest
moments in Super Bowl history and I I
you have to do something with all that
energy if I could have got outside I
think I would have started I think I
would like Superman I would have just a
cheap flight I would have flew right out
of LA and probably straight to Boston
because you know and then Tom Brady just
retired so you know I'm a very emotional
person at this moment uh thanks to him I
have no apologies yeah you're the only
person that I've seen Molly the Wonder
dog bite and she had every right to
you're not going to apologize and
Molly's not gonna apologize so the
relationship will continue to be Frosty
these some seven years later but you're
doing a lot now because you have this
new podcast called film review weekly I
believe yeah it's a film review weekly
it's exactly like title says it does
it's nothing no surprises here there's a
film review weekly I will say we started
at the end of last year we want a little
bit of Hiatus because my co-stars
actually did some international travel
Jacob London Taylor they literally had
to kind of go from the Australia to here
just to do a little La Tour you got to
hang out with a mark and it's just fun
to actually have a conversation about
movies which we're doing here I love I
need I need a venue to let out my nerd
rage or my nerd love and that's really
what this podcast is all about yeah well
that's what we do here too so is it
going to be rage your love when it comes
to the suicide squad 90 certified fresh
in the Tomato Meter so jte my simple
kickoff question to you is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about that score
kind of like I don't think it deserves a
score it has I think it's too high but
it's not a movie where I left the
theater was like oh what was that it was
a movie where I was like it was fine
it's not bad it's kind of a little bit
disappointing in some aspects but kind
of cool in others I kind of have a lot
to say about this movie so I'm really
curious to hear what you guys think
because I kind of need to bounce off you
guys to try to find out where my true
feelings for this movie is
exactly yes I need to watch you I need
the game tape
I'll I'll say Rotten Tomatoes is Right
Jack and I love watching this movie I
didn't get a chance to see it in
theaters I had it hyped up for me by a
lot of my friends saying oh it's so
fast-paced and funny and action-packed
and ridiculous and just nuts and it was
and it lived up to the building that it
had gotten so for me I think that James
Gunn lending his talents to this movie
was just such the perfect mesh I thought
the cast looked like they were having a
great time doing it and that's why I had
fun watching it so how about Jaclyn
Coley is Rotten Tomatoes wrong about 90
um no look 90 that's a little strong as
I like to say I think that's you know
James Gunn's humor because what's so
interesting about the suicide squad is
it borrows so much from like 70s
exploitation war movies sort of things
you know very sort of like dirty dozen
is like the one that people think of on
the high but there's literally like
hundreds of different languages and also
like us for versions of that same like
the ragtag group and so I really liked
how much it paid homage to that kind of
stuff you know like very low rent
exploitation stuff that only ran in one
theater in La I think James Gunn saw
those movies and he put all of that
energy into this and so I really I dug
that is it got all the connective tissue
it needs to make it work no I think
there's a lot of like what no
um
but I had fun it's a very very fun movie
it is so fun and even if you didn't like
it it is so quick it's over before you
even had a chance to think about it it
does move the the this baby hums along
like one of the vehicles that Batman was
on in the first Suicide Squad but not in
this Suicide Squad necessarily we have
our own Amanda Waller she goes by the
name producy Lucy we're gonna hear from
her in just a sec but first Jacqueline
Coley is going to do us the favor all of
our listeners and all of our viewers
from around the world Jacqueline what is
the suicide squad about well it's kind
of hard to say what V Suicide Squad
about other than to say they're a
Suicide Squad and they're going on
suicide missions but this particular
instance we open up we see Michael
Rooker playing one of these sort of
ragtag group of criminals turned saviors
and they're assembling a new group which
includes some of the old folks from the
previous iteration including Captain
Boomerang Rick Flagg we have a new
character Mr arm fall off dude let's
play button Pavilion where you can just
beat each other and they're getting
ready to like go onto this island and
sort of kill these mercenaries who have
taken over and basically what ends up
happening is uh through a course of some
of them just drowning some a lot of them
not making it and also Amanda Waller
killing some of them for not following
her orders they actually end up killing
that first group for the most part or
half of them coming up missing also
Harley Quinn was in that group as well
until the second half we have a new
Suicide Squad and that's actually the
one that we're focused in on so there
was like a plan B group and that
includes Bloodsport The Peacemaker rat
catcher and they're this sort of like
new group and they're trying to
overthrow or sort of uh rescue overthrow
the Spanish guy on this island
turns out that Harley Quinn who was
pursued to be missing is actually on the
island and she's being wooed by the
dictator and this new Suicide Squad is
like oh my gosh we should go and like
save her
because we need to get her on the squad
because the reason why they're trying to
get on that island is they're doing all
of these experiments to try and make
superhuman individual so and it's done
by The Thinker who is uh Malcolm Tucker
from in the thick of it he also played
Doctor Who and I cannot think of his
actual name right now when I think about
it but anyway his character
um has been doing all of these and the
biggest experiment that they have is the
big giant starfish so after they try to
save Harley and she ends up saving
herself they all head towards the
Thinker and they find out that the
thicker has been using these starfish to
plant them on people's heads and sort of
like control them
um also we have this random dude named
polka dot man whose mom was awful and so
now he has these blisters polka dots
that he throws on people and they blow
up they all go to the very end the polka
dot man uses it to try to attack it rat
catcher summons all of her rats her and
Bloodsport have this sort of pair where
they're trying to make sure they get
each other out of there needless to say
they all come together Harley throws the
javelin through the eye of the starfish
and they end up saving the day but not
before Peacemaker tries to kill all of
them they
decapitate him and then the post-credits
scene we figure out that he's going to
be leading a new group and that's how we
got The Peacemaker TV series boom
I feel like you just came home from
school and I asked you like what
happened today and you didn't tell me
anything about any of your classes you
just told me this like intense story
about what happened on the soccer field
at recess and I'm like wow that was that
took a lot of twists and turns that was
very exciting by the way I've loved so
much out because so much happens in this
movie some of the movies that we watch
it's like nothing happens like nothing
really happens in Mad Max they drive
there they drive back you know this
movie too many things happen too many
things happen but I got to them
so much and Peter Capaldi playing
thank you but I just call him Malcolm
Tucker in my brain because he's an
incredible the character that Dewey
Louis dreyfus's character was based off
of somewhat in Veep is Malcolm Tucker in
in the thick of it and he is a sweary
sweary British man
um producing Lucy your thoughts on The
Suicide Squad are you more of our Amanda
Waller more of our The Thinker a mixture
of both
I'm with Josh on this one I'm not
convinced it should be so high uh I
there was a lot I saw a little late so
there was a lot of people oh my God this
is the greatest movie I've ever seen so
when I went I was like what it what
really there was something missing for
me and I don't know what it is and maybe
you guys will figure that out but
something sort of fell flat I love James
Gunn I think he's awesome but I was like
something's not right about this movie
it's like not it's not hitting yeah I
think I have a reason why that we'll get
into once we start talking about the
actual film itself and we're talking
about this movie in particular because
Peacemaker is just a monster right now
streaming and everybody seems to be
enjoying that show which is obviously
the spin-off from The Suicide Squad
starring John Cena and Company so this
movie came out I don't know what it does
in years ago 20 oh no last year what
this movie is very very recent and so to
tell us what the critics were saying at
the time of its release maybe some of
those critics hyping it up for people
like Lucy and myself we turn it over to
our expert review curation manager Tim
Ryan for our segment called two minutes
with Tim he's a fellow Patriots fan JT
Tim take it away
humans with Tim for critics and
audiences The Suicide Squad from 2021
delivered what Suicide Squad from 2016
couldn't gleeful Mayhem strong
characterizations and genuine chemistry
within its collection of eccentric super
villains so why was it a disappointment
at the box office you could chalk it up
to a global pandemic or the fact that it
hit theaters in HBO Max on the same day
but a lot of people thought the main
problem was that the title was too
similar to differentiate itself from the
predecessor in the minds of moviegoers
The Suicide Squad is certified fresh at
90 on the Tomato Meter 361 reviews and
it has an 82 audience score
and just for comparison 2016's Suicide
Squad is rotten at 26 percent we covered
that one in a previous episode so what
did the critics have to say in a fresh
review Tim grierson of scream
International wrote an invigorating
blast of bloody disreputable comic book
Cinema The Suicide Squad turns its
titular criminals into a collection of
lovable anti-heroes set loose in a
dazzling surprisingly emotional
Adventure however in a rotten review
bilga iberi of New York Magazine vulture
wrote the lack of narrative momentum or
compelling character Arc starts to wear
on you the jokes get old too
the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
reads the story isn't amazing but the
over-the-top action and sometimes
literally side splitting gags make this
Suicide Squad a major Improvement so
that's the suicide squad and while
there's a few details so far on a
forthcoming sequel I'm holding out hope
it will be called a Suicide Squad I
don't know thank you guys
hey Tim you know I'm just coming off for
two years of referring to my team as the
Washington football team not a a team
Tom Brady quarterbacked a team but we
are the football team and now we're the
Washington commanders which I'm happy
about and uh I hope everybody else gets
on board so let's transition right into
movie talk let's get into the meat of
this movie hit the music Brian
foreign
hitting the Buns uh the ones and twos
there he also has some history with the
schmo's no program as does jte so JT you
and I we've been to so many screenings
together over the years did you see
Suicide Squad The Suicide Squad at a
movie theater like the weekend it opened
up was this movie that you were looking
forward to where you like I don't know
really why we're doing this so quickly
afterwards what was your first reaction
when you immediately saw the suicide
squad right afterwards yeah I got to see
it a few days earlier thanks to a friend
of ours Greg Alba from the real rejects
he had a little private screening and
it's one of those things where you walk
at a theater and you're like okay I
didn't like it I think as much as I was
supposed to but most of the people
coming out of theater were loving the
movie so you got to be that guy who's
like
yeah I liked it I mean everyone's over
here praising how funny it was when I
left the theater one of the word that
kept coming back to me was familiar I
feel like a lot of these a lot of
aspects of this movie felt like they
were grabbed from other movies even from
other James Gunn movies as you know I'm
a big Stallone fan and I was excited to
see him playing king shark but I
couldn't help but feel like that was
just an avatar for group it's just
another big strong guy who only says
very few words
bring it back you just Alba like I love
each other he's one of my favorite
actors to give him a very similar
storyline to Will Smith like I remember
a lot of people were saying oh are they
just recasting the role like no it's a
whole new character yet they give him
the same story plot with his daughter
from the first film and I'm like why
would you do that you have this whole
new character I don't even know exactly
what his powers were he's just like
another version of Deadshot like
I was like what's Happening Here I feel
it's very familiar in a lot of aspects
of the film so therefore I could have
helped but leave in the theater like wow
James Gunn is known for having this
crazy sensibility of like hard R action
Gore which you do get in this movie but
I kind of wish it felt a little bit more
original in some ways again this is
called The Suicide Squad they added a
the but it feels very similar plot wise
in a lot of ways to the first movie so I
left little underwhelmed and comedy is a
very subjective thing you know a lot of
people in my theater were laughing out
loud I never really laughed out loud
while watching this movie I chuckled I
you know I had a little smirk on my face
whereas the Guardians movies I love
those Guardian films I even love the
second one I laughed out loud throughout
both those movies and I'm wondering if
maybe James gunned for me I need that
PG-13 barrier maybe I think his jokes
are just a little bit more clever and
they just work for me better than when
he's able to have the free reign just go
full rated R blow up heads have people
get gored out I don't know it might just
be a subjective thing for me for James
Gunn maybe I like a more sedu James gun
I like a PG-13 James gun because I think
he's a little more creative and he's a
little bit funnier for me it's like
you're reading off my teleprompter
because I'm always on the on the soapbox
of movies don't need to be R to be like
hardcore and funny and I even said that
when Deadpool is coming out when
everybody said oh it has to be R-rated
I'm like well you you can make funny
things that are that are violent without
making it R-rated I think it does work
for Deadpool but I don't think it
necessarily has to be that way but I
think that Jacqueline that's one of the
appeals to a lot of folks who walked
into the suicide squad because we live
in in a day and age when you can reboot
you can have it and I I don't know a
superhero movie come out one week and if
people don't like it all right we'll
just remake it and do it different and
maybe people like it two months later
and so with this it was a super quick
turnaround and I was shocked at how
positive the reviews coming out of that
opening weekend of the suicide squad was
because we just had this one that was
very debated let's do its quality and so
now you have this one so where were you
when this movie came out were you like
oh this is it did we need this movie
uh I don't think we needed it I can
definitely say that I enjoyed it but
it's not as if I was like sitting here
like I feel like the best parts about
this movie to JT's Point I've seen in
other versions one of my favorite
moments is Harley Quinn in the dress
with her like you know Atomic blonde
like I'm gonna fight my way out the door
moment that's incredible felt like just
so awesome action filmmaking but that
was Birds of Prey that's just like the
Highlight Reel of what she did in Birds
of Prey so yeah so definitely not
necessary however
yeah I don't I don't know I honestly
don't have a good answer for you and I'm
never stumped on that I don't have a
good answer for you I think for me it's
like
I think everything that it could be a
benefit to it would also be like a disc
on the other side and I think for most
folks it wasn't about the familiarity of
it it was the fact that they did not
like what David air did so much that
James Gunn got to get the swing of this
is exactly what we wanted does that make
sense and let's be fair about this too I
mean I think folks were excited to see
James Gunn as sort of a comeback pitch
you could even go so strong as to say
and Fu because Disney had let him go
because some burial tweets had surfaced
and and and Disney fired him from making
Guardians of Galaxy 3 at the time and so
then it's like oh man well this guy we a
lot of people still think he's brilliant
what's he gonna do next he's going to
make a comic book movie for the other
team and so it it Josh it really was
like you know Tom Brady leaving New
England which is all buttoned up and
proper and then you go down to Tampa
where it's Bruce Ahrens is the coach
who's like yeah do whatever the hell you
want you you you you call the plays and
he did and I think that I think that's
why the R rating works for this and I
think that that's why all of the the
swearing and the and the Gory violence
the grotesness of a lot of the combat
scenes play so well is because it is
sort of I think fans feeling like James
Gunn can just do whatever he wants to in
this giant sandbox that he gets to play
in and not worry about the initial
Suicide Squad film that had come out
because I think that's the best way to
watch this movie is to not even consider
Suicide Squad as a movie that happened
this is a totally it's not going to
borrow any of the DNA from that's going
to borrow some of the cast but it's not
going to rely on any of the storytelling
in that movie to tell this movie so when
we get to your favorite scene you still
think this is a fresh movie JT so what
is the scene for you that makes it a
fresh film that's interesting question
because there is not a scene that
immediately jumps to my mind like
usually there's a movie I really like
I'm like oh that scene was amazing I
liked all the scenes uh I guess the I've
the scene or the sequence I like the
most is probably when it jumps back in
time during that final action sequence
where it's like John Cena's about to
shoot rat girl and also we jump back and
we get to see what happened like the
last 10 minutes previous I just like
that whole structure and the way you
just Alba falls down it's almost like
Mortal Kombat the screen has them on
each side and it's like they're about to
fight and you're like oh we're about to
get a really cool fight that's probably
the sequence to me and also king shark
like falls out and has this epic slow
motion ripping the guy apart but even
that scene let me down a little bit
because I thought it really built up for
king shark was gonna go like berserk
mode like Wolverine berserk mode he
really just rips one guy in half and
that's it I was like Oh I thought he was
really gonna tear it up Wolverine style
so every time I got excited for this
movie something kind of let me down a
little bit and also I was gonna say the
scene the very beginning where he kills
off all these character actors that we
really kind of love and got to know but
again it reminded me of Deadpool 2. I've
seen this before I've seen the same joke
done before and then another film a
comic book movie just a few years ago so
that familiar again just nothing really
surprised me really I wanted to go and
just be surprised and be shocked but
everything just felt like been there
kind of done that it tipped its hand
when it's one of my favorite scenes
though is when we when weasel jumps in
the water and we're like going on this
mission
it's just dries like wait that's the end
of week so it just said that it just
sinks and it's just so funny how how
shadowy planned this whole
genius scheme was but maybe were they
even supposed to survive at all and so
you have that in the back of your head
as you're watching all these different
action sequences play out in various
parts of the island so it was a joke
that's been told before and not even in
Deadpool 2. it reminded me of mcgruber
when we get the whole team together we
get him in the van and then the van
explodes so it's it's one of those
things they killed Captain Boomerang
though the one thing I could say Jai
Courtney is really good in is probably
the first Suicide Squad movie he's been
in a lot of movies that just haven't
lived up to like I watched Spartacus
when I first came out stars and he was a
standout in that first season and then
Captain Boomerang was the first time in
a big budget film where I'm like oh this
guy's great I was like he's really fun
in this movie I think he gets one line
in the first 10 minutes of this film and
they kill him off like okay Jai come in
for one day we're gonna kill you off
even though you're one of the few things
that first film that could really shine
a light on and be like oh man John
Courtney finally really good in a role
and they kill him like nothing I'm like
come on man yeah Jacqueline we really
didn't know who to trust because we
didn't know who was going to be
surviving to the next frame yeah that
was what was interesting about this um
for folks that don't know Michael Rooker
and uh James Gunn have a very long-term
friendship he's put him in pretty much
all of his movies uh going back to like
his early days and so when I saw Michael
Ricker I was like okay like do I give
his boy like a real like big movie to
like run and do everything and then he
kills him along with everyone else and I
was like oh this is not that tea that
being said obviously when I knew that
Idris Elba wasn't in that first group I
was very worried for every single one of
them I was like there's not enough movie
stars near this like Marco Robbie's here
but I'm I know she's making it she has a
this I it's hard to say that she's
better worse as Harley Quinn than she
was in the previous Suicide Squad film
Josh what are your thoughts on Margot
Robbie as Harley Quinn did we get more
the character and that paid off for you
was that one of the highlights for you
or did you just think that it didn't
really hit the mark you know I think
like turn more into Birds of Prey
obviously she's front and center in that
film uh I do like her in this movie I
like her when she gets to interact with
the team much like the first Suicide
Squad I think her chemistry with Will
Smith was one of the strong points but I
don't love the Side Story that she kind
of goes on with this dictator I think
this film lacks a real villain
throughout the whole film you kind of
got these like no-name generals and at
the very end starto is revealed to be
the big villain and I feel bad for
Storrow I don't even think he's the
villain of this movie he has a line
where he says I was happy and floating
in space just staring at the stars and
it like broken my heart I was like this
poor guy he was just floating in space
we we threw him in a spaceship and put
him in experiments for like 20 years or
whatever I'm like I feel bad I felt more
emotion before that sorrow bad guy
apparently the bad guy than I did for
almost anybody else in the movie I do
think this stylized stuff with Harley
Quinn's really cool I think that
sequence with the dress you know again
nothing I haven't seen in Birds of Prey
but she is so good at this role that
every time she's on screen you can't
help but just have a good time and I
liked towards the end of the film when
she finally reunites with the team and
gets to have that camaraderie with all
the other guys on the team and just kind
of joke around so for me she's great as
always she's kind of the MVP of this
series at this point uh but I think
Birds of Prey is definitely something I
would go to if I really wanted like my
Harley Quinn kick I would go to birds to
pray before this movie you on that train
as well Jacqueline uh I think yes and no
because like so I agree with you that
she is better but I really like how
they're able to one of the the issues
with Harley Quinn is because she was
introduced as such a part of the Joker
was Finding compelling stories with her
outside of the Joker storyline and so
this is another sort of bite at that
apple and I think it's like the other
side of that so I I think they need to
do this if they're going to continue to
tell stories for this character you do
need to show different sides of her like
I actually don't want to see her the way
you see her in Birds of Prey I want to
see a different like okay how can she be
almost like a glorified side B player
you know what I mean like she's like not
necessarily a part of the main I can't
say narrative because Lord knows it is
not not heavy on that but she's not a
part of that sort of main thrust forward
as far as the where the movie is going
but when she comes in and out she's
still Dynamic and we still miss her
absence and then get excited with her
coming back and I think that's actually
a better place for her to be if you look
at later Marvel that's what they're
doing with later Marvel these characters
like look at Robert Downey Jr's
character in Spider-Man uh homecoming
like that's that's a good place for her
to be I understand that concept from a
writer's standpoint even if it doesn't
make this the most I would say careful
and like
planned out uh plotting yeah I'm looking
at some of the research that our buddy
Mark Hoffmeyer did for us it's
interesting to see the the creation I'll
say of the character that Idris Elba
plays where if you're playing Bloodsport
and so everybody is going to assume that
wait okay are you is this like a reboot
of of Will Smith is this is this
something else is this like the Deadshot
character what are we looking at here
and it was a character that Gunn pretty
much had Idris Elba in mind the entire
time playing it and that's why Idris
Elba apparently signed on us because he
wanted to work with James Gunn and I
think that in a movie like this where
there's so much chaos happening and all
these characters just getting picked off
like it's like we see all these people
and I'm so happy that Pete Davidson's in
it then oh Pete Davis is not in it
anymore you need some sort of anchor I
think it herself has always been great
as that sort of anchor so I guess he'd
be the closest thing to a character you
can really glom onto and kind of hit
your wagon to in this movie and I think
that that's that's why I enjoyed it as
much as I did that and that epic fight
between flag and Peacemaker would be
like another one of the scenes I'd
really point to where you could just
tell how much fun James Gunn is having
making this movie and a lot of times
people in nitpick and they say well you
can't review a movie as being fun that
doesn't make any sense if I'm having a
good time then that's fun for me and I
especially Embrace that when it feels
like it's not always the case but it
just feels like to me that making the
movie you can't have a bad time making
that movie the way that it comes off it
seems like there was so much joy on that
set
say there's another movie currently in
theaters where this same thing does
apply and I love these movies because I
like to show them to people when people
think critics are only about you know
the next two full-esque sort of like
French New Wave auteur who's doing
experimental Cinema where they're in
their bathroom
staring at toothpaste like no that's not
the T they like critics like movies like
The Suicide Squad which has no coherent
plot it does not it does not it's got
awesomeness and the other movie is
jackass that movie is going to be
certified fresh
in a matter of minutes it like I have
not seen critics so jubilantly happy to
watch penises get hit and manipulated on
screen as they are for this Jackass
movie do not like I just wanna like
every time I'm just gonna stand there in
an abject condemnation jackass is
certified fresh
um it's it's not too far of a stone to
throw from this movie The Suicide Squad
2 jackass because it's another ragtag
group you got some veterans you got some
newcomers shout out to my bud Rachel
Wolfson and then you also have this not
really a coherent plot it's just a bunch
of different random missions where
someone's gonna get hurt what is it
about a movie like this like why do you
think the the Tomato Meter score is so
high for this movie Josh do you think it
is just because we all had such a ball
watching it even though it doesn't
necessarily follow a lot of the common
tropes that you would think for Cinema
or oscar-worthy Fair
it's an interesting question I'm not
sure I can give you a complete answer
why because I'm wrestling with the movie
myself as I talk about it I think it is
a fun time like listen even though I
sound kind of negative on this movie
it's just because I wanted to love it
instead I just liked it I would totally
recommend anybody who just wants to have
a good time in the theater listen a lot
of doing that like Jacqueline said
everybody goes in the theater to see the
Best Picture Winner nomadland some
people just want to go to a movie and
have a good time and forget whatever
worries they have during the week and
you know whatever's going on home the
theater is sometimes the place where you
just go eat a bunch of popcorn like Mark
Ellis sit down and have educating time
for two hours and this is a movie that
does that really it has a great cast I
think one of the strongest things this
movie has going for is the cast there's
so many likable people in here and they
all bring they all bring it I think
nobody in this cast is a weak point I
think everyone's great throughout like
even to the Pete Davidson has like one
little line and one little scene but if
you're a p Davidson fan you're like oh
that's a lot of fun so for me I think
it's a movie that again Rotten Tomatoes
even though it says 92 percent that
doesn't mean every person thought it was
one of the best movies of the year they
just had a good time and I think this
movie is pretty much a definition of a
good time when it comes to a comic book
big budget R-rated movie so I think
that's what it comes down to right it
came out at a very unique time in our
history because you look at the domestic
box office of The Suicide Squad 56
million dollars that sounds like a
complete bomb that how can that how can
you be talking about this movie how can
it be so well reviewed and this few
people saw it well debuted in a time
when the pandemic was happening and so
it was also on streaming at the same
time where I think a lot of folks came
to it by comparison Wonder Woman 1984
only made 47 million dollars
domestically the worldwide box office is
a little more encouraging both of those
movies tie with 167 million dollars
internationally in addition to all the
streaming and selling streaming
memberships that they got I I just go
back to where Batman and Robin happen
and and people hated it so passionately
that it seemed like Batman was dead that
you could not make another Batman movie
and then it took eight seemingly long
years it was only eight eight years
between that and Batman Begins but it
felt like a lifetime and then we get
Batman again oh and this is so awesome
but now we can just sort of snap our
fingers and reboot an entire movie we
can just say that's we didn't like what
you did with that and make it this way
is this a good thing going forward John
is this a good precedent to set or do
you think that we're just getting into
more redundant Waters going forward I
I would say first and foremost you know
the suicide squad to this day is still
being tweeted about release the air cut
that movie looks like a movie though it
does look like a film that was taken out
of the director's hands and it was given
to a trailer company to edit
because the trailer was such a big hit
with all the music from Queen it had a
certain Vibe and then when they were
test grading it it wasn't that movie it
was they were selling a different movie
than what I think David Ayer made and WB
you got to give some credit they've
gotten their stuff together they were a
mess I think early in the DCU I mean the
whole Josh Whedon just League that's a
whole
you could do a whole podcast just on a
series of podcasts just on that thing
yeah we don't need to
um so for me I think DC is finally doing
what
most studios are doing is they're giving
the director the Reigns they're letting
them here's you know they're obviously
going to have their fingers in a little
bit but they're for the most part they
seem to be like hey here's here's the
property pick just what you want we're
going to let you do to the best that we
can without getting too much involved
because this at the end of the day does
feel like a James Gunn movie you watch
Slither you watch super this feels like
a James Gunn film you watch Aquaman that
feels like a James wand film uh so I
think they're doing a really good job of
like the directors kind of you know own
these films I think they're learning
from their mistakes specifically for WB
and DCU and it makes me more excited for
the films they have going forward like
I think the first suicide squad has some
things that are decent I think Will
Smith is a bigger lead than Aegis Alvin
I think he's just more charismatic and
when it comes to that box office Will
Smith is going to put some butts and
seats when you do a summer big action
movie you just I believe I don't think
has quite that kind of pull yet
um so for me I think that maybe goes
back to the box office yes the pandemic
was a huge Factor there too but King
Kong Godzilla Converse Godzilla they
that did big numbers but you had two
giant IPS
facing each other and every kid knows
who that is nobody knows who blood sport
is I hear Bloodsport I think John Claude
Van Damme it's the first thing that pops
in my mind so I never heard of this
character before but you know what Will
Smith's character I actually heard of
his character before he's somebody in
the comics that's a little more front
center he's more of a known as a Batman
villain so for me all those things are
kind of like factors the James gun of it
I'm just gonna bring in this more of
like industry thing what are brothers
when Disney made that mistake which
Disney of course realized was mistake
that's why they hired him back there's a
lot of Bad actors in everything that
happened to James Gunn they wanted to
get into James Gunn business because for
folks that don't remember James Gunn's
sort of trauma which folks if you don't
know trauma the Toxic Avenger uh Swamp
Thing those are all made by the studio
called trauma they were known for like
really gory horror and genre type fair
and that's literally where James Gunn
learned how to make filmmakers I think
Roger Corman think very sort of you know
low budget quick make it happen and that
kind kind of filmmaker that kind of
writer director filmmaker is brilliant
because they have the entire DC EU
catalog and he can go through that and
be like what can I take
what can I blend what can I move like
arm fall off boy is like a legit thing
from the comics and that is the type of
thing that James Gunn can do that's why
you're able to take something like
Guardians of the Galaxy and turn it into
a billion dollar franchise that's what
they wanted and so I really don't blame
them for like hopping them up it makes
sense he's somebody who can make
something out of nothing and I think
that's what makes him like an invaluable
sort of filmmaker also shout out to the
two DC EU animated films Suicide Squad
uh hell to pay and assault on Arkham I
love
I love uh both of those and I think
they're better than anything that wdb
has done live action sorry wow okay
there you go all right they're they're
really good they're really good the
director thing brings up an interesting
topic because JT you said that you
prefer the the MCU James Gunn to the the
DC I guess we still refer to it
loosley's the dceu James Gunn simply
because you do like some sort of
um you know limitations I guess when it
comes to storytelling or violence or
language and and that kind of stuff and
you think that the jokes work better in
Guardians of the Galaxy I said at the
time and and I think I still feel this
way is that I think sometimes we do get
to beholden to a specific director where
I I don't think that James Gunn is the
only person competent enough to make a
great Guardians of the Galaxy movie so I
didn't agree with Disney firing him at
all but I also think that somebody else
could have come in and made a great
Guardians 3. I'm happy he's back doing
it but if he's doing something else like
The Suicide Squad I think that I might
appreciate that a little bit I want to
see what else James Gunn does and going
back to Guardians 3 is that something
that excites you or is that something
where you're like but we've seen him do
those let him do something else no
because like I was saying earlier I
think that for some reason that property
seems to bring the best out of him and
like I said because some of the things
in this movie reminded me of guardians
galaxy so to me it's like okay he kind
of already found his Lane with guardians
it's cool that he got to make Suicide
Squad movie because he got to really
push that R rated Gore level but for me
Tycoon TD is going to direct the
Guardians of the Galaxy in the beginning
of this new Thor movie I think tyke is a
director if James Gunn couldn't make it
for this third film he's somebody who
could have he's already an MCU he
probably could have gone in there and
made a really good guardians of galaxy
film I think James Gunn is also I think
he's obviously talking to taika and I
think he's helping guide his hand a
little bit for the beginning of you know
Thor love and thunder so I do think
somebody else could come in and make
another Guardians film but I'm glad he's
the one doing it because I really love
those for first two films I'm in that
rare category where I kind of enjoyed
volume two more than I did the first
film and I remember watching the first
film with you Ellis we we got an early
screening for that and again I love that
movie and I loved seeing this fresh new
take on MCU and I love seeing James guns
his humor his humor really just comes
through in those movies it's not that I
don't think he should make R-rated
movies or he needs to go Violet just for
me specifically I think it just works
better for me when he's in the guardian
Universe where he can't explode people
and rip people in half that I don't like
that stuff I love that stuff but for me
it just works better for gun to be in
that Garden's Galaxy exactly does it
feel like James Gunn is this nice Family
Guy when he's making the Guardians
movies and then he just had this crazy
weekend in Vegas with his buddies away
from the the wife and the kids and he
just got to go nuts and make this movie
and then now he's back to the suburbs
and we're gonna get another Guardians
three I mean to a certain extent
um you know JC you mentioned like you
know you feel like WB got together
they're letting these directors uh have
have more freedom and I think to a
certain respect you're right but I think
it is more about the framework because
like when you look at something like
Peacemaker and what they were able to do
to push forward and make that a series
you don't do that unless you've already
sort of looked at what what Disney is
doing with Disney plus I really don't
think it's so much that Warner Brothers
got it together I just think they
understood it was not about making an
extended universe that looked exactly
like the MCU it was about taking the
aspects of that universe that works and
applying it to your universe and like
Sony's already doing that like Sony is
literally showing with like maybe with
morbius but definitely with Venom how
they're going to be able to like play
but they don't have to feel like these
all these people need to like literally
team up to do something they can they
can just figure out a way to understand
like yes these all play on the same
chessboard but they don't have to be
playing the same game and you talk about
a spin-off show that in my opinion
because I think Rotten Tomatoes is right
here I I love The Suicide Squad 90
totally fair Peacemaker is blowing me
away I am amazed with how funny it is
with how quick it is with how great John
Cena is I I he was greatest Peacemaker
in the movie but the fact that he is
carrying this show and you have great
supporting casts in there too I just I
fell in love with this show from the
first episode from the first time he
gave eagley a hug I knew that this was a
special program JT are you in on
Peacemaker is it or are you feeling
yourself a little left out in the cold
with this one too no I'm really enjoying
Peacemaker more so than I did uh Suicide
Squad I think John Cena is so right for
that character and I think maybe the 30
minute block that they're they're
limited to per episode is just a perfect
amount of this kind of James Gunn
content for me I think like a two hours
Suicide Squad again had a fun time but I
feel like Peacemaker he's even allowed
to go a little bit farther than he was
able to go in the suicide squad and I
think maybe that's even better for him
if I'm gonna have him go R rated and
over the top maybe I need to go a little
bit farther than what he could do in a
movie theater maybe it's a little better
for HBO and streaming because HBO they
don't care their gloves are off they're
like you can do whatever you want just
make sure you have an episode at the end
of the week so maybe that works even
better for me on HBO
the Jacqueline Coley take on Peacemaker
is so Jacqueline is in the middle of
awards season I tried I really did try I
really did try I was like I don't want
to say it I'm sorry I watched the movie
I watched this movie obviously you did
your homework I did my homework and then
they were like Mark was like and I'm
gonna watch like a couple episodes of
Peacemaker and I was because I like
actually saw Mark Ellis it was funny our
ships crossed paths in real life ladies
and gentlemen uh the other day uh
yesterday sorry and uh I was thinking to
myself I was like that's probably not
gonna happen
all right
all right I'll stay with you and I'll
flip the question into this
if you had to have a show based on your
knowledge of The Suicide Squad
which character do you want to see get a
spin-off who's your favorite character
from The Suicide Squad that you're like
I want more from them it could be Harley
Quinn it could be Peacemaker it could be
it could be weasel pre-drafted what are
you talking about the best character is
weasel
I absolutely want to know what the hell
first of all joke of jokes that's uh his
brother that's John Young who also was
the body of Groot and Rocket through
several of both of the so the voices are
done by Vin Diesel and Bradley Cooper
but on set he plays their physical uh
manifestations and acts alongside the
characters and he's actually shown up in
the in the movies as the actual
character as well he's a great actor but
he gave
it like that is some childhood you broke
my Tonka truck being manifested in real
life you uh what are you gonna give me a
part oh yeah bro which one he's good The
Great Character
will be I don't think he could talk
weasel and king shark together just let
them have it weasel and king shark The
Adventures of weasel and king shark come
on yeah it's like Calvin Hobbes I love
it
um JT I'll close out here with you your
uh your final thoughts on uh The Suicide
Squad including which character would
you trust on an actual Mission the
character I would trust on the actual
Mission well it's not John Cena because
he killed one of my favorite characters
in the movie uh let's see who did I
trust I guess right you gotta go with
red girl red girl I think it was kind of
the highlight of the movie for me a lot
of ways I think her story you know again
talking about Techo my TV just a little
bit a little Cameo from him playing the
dad is it rat catcher is that what his
name is yeah rat catcher I think she was
one of the you know highlights of the
movie for me and I love that little
emotional Arc you get the final finale
where she calls on the chart all the
sharks all the rats and you get that
flashback to her father
why rat Papa
rats are the loneliest and most despised
of All Creatures my love
if they have purpose
so do we off
[Music]
so yeah if you're gonna do a series I
would like to see one with her because I
think she was not fleshed out enough
because with all these characters you
can only do so much for each character
and I think she's somebody who like with
her backstory I could I would love to
see a movie just about her or a series
on HBO Max about her I think that'd be
fantastic the movie to me again it's a
good time I just didn't love it like a
lot of my uh colleagues I had a good
time watching it as well as movies I
could watch and if it's on TV if it's on
a certain part I'll stop and I'll watch
it for like 15-20 minutes I think the
back half of the movie Works more for me
than the first half I think with Harley
Quinn kind of goes off into his own
little Mission it's not as interesting
to me and they go drinking One Night in
a bar it's fun to see those people
together but the movie really comes
alive for me in the second half when you
introduce Taro and this giant like Kaiju
Beast going around destroying everything
that's when the movie really kind of
comes alive visually and just you know
fun factor for me so it's a good movie
it's a fun movie it's a movie I might
like more as the years go by I might
have more references film them as time
goes by that happens with some movies
for me so I'm excited to you know
revisit it and who knows maybe we'll get
a sequel I don't know if they Greenland
one yet I don't think they have but
James Gunn did come back to another one
of these I would of course go see
opening weekend and I will say that I
also loved Alice Braga as Seoul but my
favorite character in both Suicide Squad
movies and it's hard to go against my
guy Will Smith Viola Davis is Amanda
Waller is just so good and so convincing
and I do love what they did with the
storyline back at headquarters here
where you do have this little Rebellion
that goes on I thought that was an
interesting thing to sort of watch play
out because there's elements of mcgruber
like I mentioned but they're also it it
felt sort of like Cabin in the Woods
where we just have this like fun gaggle
of office employees who are watching
this Mass Destruction play out not for
their own Amusement necessarily but
they're having a good time doing it
can I say one thing about that Amanda
Waller scene if you watch the first
Suicide Squad she 187 to her whole crew
at one point just because they're in the
room and this girl knocked her out with
a golf club and they just stayed around
they should all been dead the second she
woke up she should have came in with a
Tommy guy yes yes thank you the fact
that she's just like licking her wounds
yeah I'm like you must be dying a cancer
heifer because that is not the way you
dealt with this did y'all know I just
saw this in the research too that uh
James Gunn is uh buddies with Michael
Rooker as we mentioned they go way back
he keeps killing him off in movies
so the spoiler word for some other James
Gunn production so Slither Michael
Rooker blows up in super his head gets
slammed the belko experiment I remember
that that's a fun movie gets his head
smashed and then Guardians of the Galaxy
2 obviously has a very emotional moment
with Star Wars and then the suicide
squad his head explodes so if you're a
fan of a Michael Rooker character in a
James Gunn movie don't get too attached
um but I am always attached at the hip
to a former intern at chmos no former
engineer at schmoz no now doing
wonderful things on his own jte movie
thinks he does a lot of reviews there
then also film review weekly the new
podcast with Jacob Taylor and jte I know
that those are some places that the kids
can check out your latest workout what
else is going on what do you got in the
pipeline what's your social media handle
sir
yeah at jte movie thinks on Twitter I
don't really use Instagram so just hit
me up on Twitter yeah just around La
watching movies you know I like to just
go up to random people after a movie and
tell them my review because I gotta tell
somebody and if they're not listening
podcast I'll just go up to complete
strangers and be like here's what I
thought about this movie and usually
they run away you would rather navigate
the Cesspool that is Twitter over than
just post some lovely you have a
beautiful dog
he does have his own Instagram I believe
it's at Dalton the Bulldog good okay
feel free to go look at him he's
adorable oh he's such a sweetheart too
all right Bud well it's always good
catching up with you man um and thank
you for wearing that shirt I don't know
if we highlighted it for all of our
listeners out there jte went a and got
himself a Van Halen shirt was that just
for the show
uh yeah well I bought it because I do
love Van Halen um and you know Ready
Player one had a great trailer that that
Van Halen made Ready Player one in my
opinion thank you especially when it
came to the trailer uh the movie was fun
that's a whole other episode but yeah
Van Halen come on I had to show some
love for Marcos all right jack we got to
get out of here because uh you have a
Super Bowl party to prepare for and you
can try to convince me to come over I'm
just gonna be watching it in the comfort
of my own home me and Molly the Wonder
Dog but this has been the suicide squad
with our special guest jte for him for
Jacqueline Coley for producing Lucy
engineer Brian and everybody here the
team at Rotten Tomatoes Dalton the
bulldog and Molly the Wonder Dog and
Jacqueline you're how's your pup okay
we'll we'll talk on Transformers we
gotta get out of here my name is Mark
Ellis thank you all for listening we'll
catch you next time on Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong
[Music]
thank you